[Music]
we're gonna get started everybody thank
you so much for joining us today I hope
you enjoyed the keynote a lot of great
speakers there and we have some
excellent content for you today my name
is Brian singer I am the head of cloud
commerce product cloud commerce
encompasses our GCP marketplace product
as well as orbit era white label
marketplaces and multi cloud billing we
also have Roger pulse with us today
Roger is the EVP and chief innovation
officer at Pitney Bowes and he's going
to talk a little bit about Pitney Bowes
is digital transformation and efforts to
build an ecosystem so I think one of the
exciting things about cloud is I've seen
it mature is that the strategies around
why we're using cloud and why it's
important to our companies have really
evolved in the beginning we were moving
to cloud to save money right we could
pay by the drink we could use services
only as we needed them and it was a lot
quicker to provision a VM to get
something up and running as we've gotten
a little bit smarter about how we use
cloud security has actually become a
driver right what Google is able to do
with security and its data centers and
what we're able to do with increasing
levels of automation is secure our
workloads in the cloud to a level that
we've never been able to do before and
as we've solved these problems right and
as we've been able to get better
economies of scale out of cloud we've
actually started to unlock new products
in ecosystems so cloud and some of the
characteristics of cloud have actually
allowed us to create products that could
not have existed before cloud cloud
platforms evolved and that's really what
we're gonna talk about today is right
how do we actually monetize a product
that we've built in cloud so we'll look
a little bit about pricing strategies
and things like that and then how do we
build an ecosystem around a platform
because as we as we've seen some of the
most valuable companies and products
that are out there today actually are
products that have enabled an ecosystem
right so we think about building a
product for cloud we have to answer some
key questions one how do we monetize it
what's the right way to ask our customer
to pay for that service and every
company out there and you'll hear from
Roger right Pitney Bowes you know
started as a shipping company and you'll
see every company is actually evolving
into more of a traditional ISV software
provider as our data is moving to cloud
and as more of the services that we
provide to our customers are digital
everyone needs to start thinking about
how do we become a software vendor
ourselves right and inherent to that is
understanding the billing models that
are available to us in cloud and which
models are right for us as we build
these services and this is important to
everybody in a company from the beady
guy who's going out and selling it to
the developer who's actually building
the product because you actually have to
think about the pricing in the billing
model as you build out the product and
you'll see why in a few slides
so in the cloud there's a couple of
billing models that have become you know
very common and there's some good
reasons for that first is a subscription
model which everyone is probably
familiar with we all have subscriptions
in our day to day lives the key things
to think about when it comes to
subscription are that it's based on a
cap set of usage so you set the
threshold for what a customer can use
right typically within a plan and you
know that's basically you know the
amount that you're going to charge them
in any given month for use of that
subscription works great for non
variable workloads where it's not
changing that much if you think about
like network usage for example that
could change a lot over the course of a
month so it's not great to have a
subscription to a network you know to a
certain amount of bandwidth but
consumption on the other hand
usage-based pricing has become much more
common for cloud services right we use
consumption pricing for GCP for virtual
machines we use consumption pricing for
storage and this is based on the actual
usage of a product and we think about
this as being best for variable
workloads when you don't necessarily
have a flat amount of usage over many
months or in a given month and you want
to build a customer for exactly what
they're using
so looking a little bit more closely at
subscription right
it's that fixed monthly price usually
prorated to a given date and there's a
few actions that are usually available
to a customer when they have a
subscription such as upgrading or
downgrading between plans um there's
actually a lot of complexity here that
you need to think about when building
out your service because the upgrade and
the downgrade could be manual you could
say to a customer we're gonna cut you
off unless you go upgrade your plan it
could also be automated based on certain
business logic or rules that you want to
put in place right you could say we're
going to let you use up to a certain
amount and if you go over that we're
going to put you into another tier
alright so when you think about
monetizing your service you have to make
sure you have a platform that can
support whatever model it is that you
choose the other thing that's very
interesting about subscriptions is that
you can have what we call a one to many
relationship between the entitlement
which is the thing that the customer is
actually buying from buying from you and
the pricing plan that they're that
they're using what this means is you
could have for example one plan that is
a yearly commitment that's paid monthly
and you could have another plan that is
a yearly commitment that's played you
paid yearly all right both for the same
entitlement in either case the customers
actually gonna be paying a different
amount most likely but they're paying
for the same thing and this one too many
relationship is really core to how
subscriptions work so moving on to
consumption billing there's a few
different types of consumption billing
that you could insert that you could
build into a service that you have on
demand is obviously the most simple it's
just what I'm using times the price for
each item in the case of GCP there's a
price for a VM for an hour all right you
take the number of hours of that VM and
multiply it by the price and that gives
you your total cost and so the benefit
of this is it's very simple easy to
understand right the drawback is that
it's also a little bit inflexible which
is why we have what we call tiered
pricing for consumption as well and with
what this means is that as you start to
use more right you pay less and you see
this more in storage and net
working and things like that where you
know you kind of expect to derive some
economies of scale you can see the
example here where as we go from you
know 20 widgets to 30 widgets to 30 plus
the actual price per widget is coming
down and the the cost right in each tier
there gets lower and lower the the nice
thing here is that as the customer is
using more right they're getting the
benefit of that discount which is
actually going to keep them consuming
from you if there's other alternatives
one of the most popular models that we
see out there though is what we call a
base Plus consumption model this
combines elements of subscription
billing with consumption billing if you
think about a committed use discount in
GCP for example right there is
essentially a subscription a commitment
and then there is a per widget fee or
you know per hour fee if you go over
that the benefit of this is that it
allows you to charge the customer for
the you know basic level of what they're
going to use right you can probably
forecast that they're gonna have some
basic level of usage and you can lock
that in you can give them a discount for
that and then anything over that right
they're still able to consume but
they're just gonna pay a little bit more
and this tends to be the most flexible
and actually confers a lot of benefits
to everybody one of the things that you
need to think about though if you are
going to do consumption billing is what
are the metrics you're going to bill
against some of the common metrics that
we see are time so
number of hours for example that
somebody's using your service data how
much data is stored sorry how much data
is being transferred storage or just a
count of something right it could be the
number of connections that the users
made made to the service the key is that
you know this is where the the business
really has to come together with the
engineering team to figure out what are
the right metrics and then how do we
count them and how do we monetize on
them for our service so just putting it
all together real quickly if whether you
have a subscription or a consumption
plan
right you actually have to figure out
what is the route to market then for
this product so you have a few different
options you could sell it directly to an
end customer you could also bring it to
market through a public cloud
marketplace like TCP marketplace and you
can also sell it through your own
channel no matter what the billing model
is though you have to make sure that
billing model fits with the go to market
that you're choosing for your product so
great you've created a wonderful new
product on cloud you've added
monetization you've picked your route to
market now comes the fun part
where you actually get to go build an
ecosystem around this product now I
think it's important to note that an
ecosystem is not an app store and just
because you have an app store it doesn't
mean you have an ecosystem I actually
found this this definition in a paper as
I was preparing for this talk and I
really thought it did a good job of
outlining what an ecosystem actually is
so I'm gonna read it real quick a
software ecosystem is a set of actors
functioning as a unit and interacting
with a shared market for software and
services right these relationships are
frequently underpinned by a common
technological platform or market and
operate through the exchange of
information resources and artifacts so
the really interesting thing to me is
that all ecosystems have this common
technological platform in common right
and this is really core to actually
being able to build out an ecosystem so
if you think about what has to be in
place before you can even think about
creating an ecosystem around your
product you have to have this common
tech platform it also really helps to
have a stable customer base so if you
don't have customers that are using your
product it's very hard to attract other
companies to build around the platform
that you've created so it's a question a
lot you know that we get a lot of the
time is you know should I work on
building the ecosystem first or building
the customer base first I would say that
building the customer base is very very
important because it's hard to attract
that ecosystem if you don't have it in
the first place your customers also need
to be engaged with your platform an
ecosystem will only really
if they believe that they can make money
by working with you and with your with
your customers and if the customers
aren't engaged with the platform it's
hard to actually get that flywheel
spinning and then finally you have to be
able to create a trusted relationship
with your customers what you're doing
effectively by creating an ecosystem and
maybe wrapping an app store around it is
saying that you actually believe these
solutions are good right there they're
your customers are going to be able to
use them they're going to work etc etc
and if you don't have that trusted
relationship with your customers it's
very difficult to get them to start
using third-party software in terms of
the actual product requirements couple
things have to be in place first of all
you have to be able to support the
exchange of information in today's world
that usually means that your platform
has open api's that third parties can
use so if you have data right that you
know it's part of your platform that
you're making available to your
customers you want other third parties
to be able to provide services on top of
that you have to have some way for them
to get at that data so open API is
extensibility are very important in
creating an ecosystem a couple great
examples everyone's probably familiar
with Google Play I think actually sundar
talked about the Android ecosystem a
little bit it's more than just obviously
the App Store it's all the telcos all
the customers all the app app makers
right and all of these entities are
working together to deliver value to the
end-user the common tech platform in
this case is obviously the Android
operating system right and you can kind
of see how some of the elements in that
definition applied to Android GCP is
another example of an ecosystem right
we're all here we're all part of that
ecosystem and some of the things we're
trying to do to help that ecosystem
organize and form are things like GCP
marketplace which we've made available
so just a quick bit like why are
ecosystems important I think some of
this goes without saying but for one it
increases loyalty and and stickiness
from the customers right if they if
they're getting products not just from
you but from other entities right and
you're facilitating that they're gonna
stick with you over the long term second
it helps fill gaps in the platform
offering it's very difficult to have a
solution that solves all the problems
that your customers want you to solve
right you will not be able to hire
enough engineers to make that happen but
if you have a robust ecosystem they can
fill in these gaps and then finally it
gives you avenues for additional
monetization and value creation so it
goes without saying if you have build a
marketplace people are going to be
buying things from that marketplace and
whoever is facilitating that that that
transaction is able to take a little bit
you know a little bit of that value that
they're creating
so the ecosystems can actually form
without you doing anything right you'll
see if you have a great product and
customers come into that product other
third parties are going to want to get
engaged but for it to really organize
and monetize effectively it helps to
actually have a place to for customers
to go to discover solutions and procure
them and so on so in terms of actually
operationalizing we look at it from two
sides the partner sides so these are the
entities that are creating value-added
solutions around your products right and
in the case of them there's really three
things to think about onboarding and
this means bringing them into your
ecosystem right getting the contracts
signed you know doing doing sort of the
the actual product integration work
certification so that means looking at
the solutions that you're bringing in to
the end of the plat into the marketplace
and actually running them through some
sort of certification process so that
when your customers are using them they
can be relatively assured that they're
going to work right and they can trust
the solutions that are available from
your partners and then finally go to
market alright it's not enough to just
usually put solutions out there
your partner's you know whoever is
participating your ecosystem is going to
need help selling on the customer side
there's some basic things that customers
need in order to make the ecosystem
effective they have to be able to find
the solutions that are out there all
right this is where the AppStore becomes
very important app store marketplace
whatever you want to call it they have
to be able to purchase purchase
solutions and it really helps for them
to be able to purchase from a central
entity right you don't want your
customers to be able to have to go to
many different entities in the you know
many different organizations right to
use products along with with your
platform you want them to be able to
centralize that procurement and then
finally provisioning that is basically
how are they going to use these
third-party products right provisioning
can mean a lot of different things it
could mean deploying a VM right to to a
cloud platform it could just mean
turning on an API all three of these
things need to work really really easily
for your customers to have a robust
ecosystem so at orbit era we've actually
built a solution to help you jump-start
your efforts with this right we can't
solve every problem that you have for
building an ecosystem but some of the
things we just talked about in terms of
onboarding partners and actually making
your solutions discoverable and making
it easy to integrate and and provision
are things that or the orbital white
label marketplace is able to help with
and we'll hear from Roger pills in just
a few minutes about how Pitney Bowes is
using orbit era to build a an ecosystem
marketplace for their customers actually
perfect timing so I'm going to welcome
Roger up on stage Rogers the executive
vice president and CIO at Pitney Bowes
take it away Roger
alright great good to be here I'm gonna
share pennyvos journey I'm sure part of
it is unique to our company but
hopefully some of it is helpful and
sounds familiar to what some of you are
going through in your own companies
Pitney Bowes is a hundred-year-old
company we have had a long history in
office equipment and services around
mail
and shipping as Brian went through and
our general set of solutions ultimately
power Commerce hundred years into it we
had a new CEO come on board six years
ago we've undertaken a pretty dramatic
digital transformation part of the
transformation relates to a couple of
billion dollars of acquisitions in the
software space that started ten years
ago so in addition to the mailing and
shipping heritage were in three
categories of software one is customer
information management we do data
quality for customers like
salesforce.com weren't location
intelligence we sell data that customers
like Twitter and Facebook and customer
engagement so as we went through our
digital transformation it was a huge
help that we had 800 software developers
and a software business we partnered
closely with G who didn't necessarily
have that and it's been a key part of
our transformation of mailing and
shipping and then the last piece of the
equation has been really important and
that's ecommerce services we do all of
eBay's global shipping platform and have
grown our global shipping business and
our domestic ecommerce business to a
billion dollars now so between that and
software it's half of our company and we
got our first taste of creating an
ecosystem based on a platform in that
e-commerce business and that ultimately
led to partnering with Google for our
SMB business but in our in our
e-commerce business we're actually both
supporting eBay and also 250 retailers
we're connecting millions of sellers
millions of buyers hundreds of retailers
tens of payments companies tens of
shippers via the pennyvos commerce cloud
so that ended up facilitating from zero
to almost two billion dollars of gross
merchandise value by creating that
platform in that ecosystem and in our
newer business so based on that we said
everything we learned let's take that to
a very traditional business of ours
which was what we were known for which
is postage meters and a million small
businesses using postage meters so it's
a little bit of our head
three the journey has involved a
tremendous amount of technology change
and that actually was very very critical
to the building of an ecosystem
Brian referred a couple times to up to a
platform and I think a key part of the
journey of building this ecosystem has
been a very persistent building of a
platform over multiple years our CEO was
very forward-looking kind of not what
I've been used to to be honest but he
really encouraged us to follow a journey
we basically laid out a set of
technology drivers like you'll see at
events like this built a commerce cloud
and there were three pillars of our of
our transformation one was designed so
many of you at your companies I'm sure
you have design initiatives but design
and client experience was very very
critical for those million small
businesses we actually built a client
portal so we have four million logins
now a quarter and that was very critical
as we started to build this ecosystem
and this marketplace so design and
client experience and creating a web
experience was the first piece of it the
second piece of it was was data in a
data platform so as we were progressing
on this journey we built one very large
data platform big data platform that
served all the company's data needs it
became our IOT platform it became our BI
platform it became our tracking platform
so we've got 30 products across the
company leveraging our big data platform
and it's also the place where we create
data about our customers and that also
will feed into the App Store in the
marketplace so as we build IOT
capabilities we built web capabilities
we started to build increasing amounts
of data about our million SMB customers
and that's actually going to be very
critical to to our app store in our
ecosystem creation so that was a very
critical piece of the puzzle and then
lastly as in terms of foundations of our
platform we basically transitioned our
entire 100-year
company to the cloud just just went
all-in so we've got 35 SAS products
those SMBs those million SMBs almost
200,000 now have a SAS of or IOT product
of some sort so you know we used to be
an office equipment company we sort of
shifted to a cloud centric client
experience and then started offering our
own IOT or SAS products to those
customers and we sort of changed the
center of gravity of the company of the
company from sort of office equipment
and a phone experience to a cloud and
SAS based experience based on the
commerce cloud so SAS was critical to it
api's was critical to it Brian mentioned
open open platforms and api's so a big
reason why we're here working with orbit
era is several years ago we jumped in
with Apogee which is the API management
platform that Google bought and we built
our whole API platform based on Apogee
now Google apogee we've got four hundred
api's on that a business that was
nothing grew to a 120 million annualized
based on that API platform and so as we
built this platform an ecosystem were
able to launch hackathons and developer
programs and they're all leveraging all
of our solutions via that Google Apogee
API platform and then lastly we jumped
in with mobile and that's another reason
why we partnered with Google the the
Apogee experience was really really good
and we ultimately changed that office
equipment to be Android based thinking
you know we want to build ecosystems but
we're also riding others ecosystems and
platforms so we went all-in and our
latest generation of office equipment we
launched at Google's New York
headquarters last September it's Android
based it was the best-selling new
product launch we ever had we've already
sold over 60,000 of them and we've
actually become a relatively mature
mobile centric IOT based company we
partnered with the gentleman that
created the nest thermos
that now part of Google and so those
devices would kind of transform them
like nest transform thermostat so
they're now they're digital IOT
connected to our commerce cloud based on
on Google so that's sort of our journey
it's a little bit of context for the
conversation ultimately it's about
business outcomes I was emailing with my
boss our CEO on the flight and he just
pretty much doesn't care about anything
I said except for the business outcome
so from from a business perspective
we've been able to create six hundred
million of revenue from the Pitney Bowes
commerce cloud all of our 150 million of
revenue growth last year was based on
new products and we've got as I
mentioned about two hundred thousand SAS
customers saved about fifteen million
across a year and growing reduced cycle
time a lot and really transformed the
client experience to one that was really
old-school to something that's very
digitally centric at that point that
kind of brings us to where we are today
so this is I think my second to last
slide it's very very complicated so I'll
just walk through it so the reason why
I'm speaking here with Brian is the next
step of that journey in building the
cloud was to build an ecosystem for our
million SMB customers just like we did
in our e-commerce business unit so Brian
mentioned trust when we surveyed our
customers related to our brand that was
fortunately one of the things about our
brand that stood out was trust and we're
an honest company and we try to do the
right thing by our our clients and I
think those stable relationships the
million customers very engaged like
Brian said and that trust was sort of
the foundation for what we're doing here
so I'll try to walk you through this
hyper complicated chart so in the center
is the Commerce Cloud which is all those
platform elements that I talked about on
the prior page and the bottom left is
our alanis latest generation of postage
meters or latest generation of office
equipment so roll back five years all we
had was office equipment then we built
the commerce cloud and then in the top
right basically our hundred year history
for which most of us haven't been
495 of the years we were intermediating
ten billion dollars of postage between
the USPS and a million SMB so we're
basically a one product company
intermediating one partner so we wanted
to get increased stickiness like Brian
described we wanted to bring more value
to our clients like Brian described and
we wanted to fill gaps in our portfolio
like Brian described so what we
ultimately did based on the Commerce
cloud and leveraging the data we had
about our customers is adopted the
orbiter our platform we actually made
the decision at Google cloud next last
year and what we're doing now is we're
essentially pivoting so those million
SMB customers that used to only have one
product we're now bringing additional
mobile apps on the Android based
solutions delivered via the Orbitz era
app store additional Pitney Bowes assets
and third-party SAS apps delivered from
the App Store and then ultimately it's
tied together with that web experience
that I described which is we call your
account and then on this side which is
sort of the other end of the other side
of the two-sided marketplace we've
gradually over the last two years
pivoted with additional services started
with USPS two years ago we started
intermediating services from FedEx and
UPS as well all via those same SAS
solutions we wrap it all with our
payment solutions and now based on
Orbitz era and Apogee we're bringing
more and more third parties into the mix
through our app store delivered on the
Android based devices or via SAS via
your account so called multiple delivery
methods multiple partners and the Orbitz
era and the apogee and the Google Cloud
is making it possible so ultimately I
already went through sort of why we're
doing it additional value stickiness
filling in gaps improving our small
businesses productivity and I think
that's that's about it so I think we're
gonna have a little Q&A now so hopefully
that is somewhat helpful to some of your
journeys
[Music]